economía en francés 24 me acompaña en el
estudio mi compañera daniela blandón
daniela buenas noches bienvenida vamos a
comenzar hablando de la cob 26 en
glasgow en escocia en donde la economía
fue la gran protagonista de la jornada
de hoy así de santiago muy buenas noches
pues las grandes instituciones privadas
de crédito de 45 países se
comprometieron a financiar la
descarbonización mundial de aquí a mitad
de siglo se trata de 450 bancos que
manejan la no despreciable suma de 130
billones de dólares en patrimonio o el
40 por ciento del capital mundial entre
ellos están gigantes financieros como el
hsbc el banco santander el deutsche bank
jaypee morgan y hasta un colombiano
bancolombia que son instituciones
habidas de prestar dinero pues aunque no
dieron una cifra exacta si anticiparon
que contribuirán con una parte justa en
el esfuerzo para alejar al mundo de los
combustibles fósiles escuchamos
miras hacia arriba hoy y ves que 130
billones de dólares en el núcleo de las
finanzas globales están diciendo
buscamos proyectos alineados con la meta
de cero emisiones y estamos felices de
llegar a una gran empresa siderúrgica de
automóviles de tecnología lo que sea les
prestaremos el dinero o invertiremos en
usted si tiene un plan para reducir esas
emisiones pero si no tiene un plan lo
siento no funciona
también hablemos ahora de américa latina
porque habrá un bono azul para financiar
precisamente proyectos que sean
ambientales pues él anunció precisamente
el banco interamericano de desarrollo en
el marco de esta cumbre climática de la
que estamos hablando se trata de un bono
por 50 millones de dólares australianos
ligados a la salud del océano y a la
limpieza del agua en latinoamérica y el
caribe por expliquemos santiago un poco
que es un bueno esto es un papel que
emiten las empresas o instituciones o
también los gobiernos en este caso el
bid y quienes invierten reciben
intereses hasta que les devuelvan el
dinero que prestaron en este caso 10
años por lo general es a mediano oa
largo
la categoría de sostenible significa que
los bonos ligados a este bono van a ser
invertidos en garantizar la
disponibilidad del agua y saneamiento en
la región y pasemos ahora a eeuu porque
la reserva federal comenzará a retirar
algunos de los estímulos qué significa
esto para la economía y financieramente
hablando pues santiago desde que comenzó
la pandemia en marzo de 2020 el banco
central de eeuu inició un proceso para
mantener a flote la economía que
consistió en varias herramientas pero
dos de las más importantes fueron
reducir las tasas de interés para
incentivar el consumo y relajar también
las condiciones financieras pero también
hay una tercera y es que aumentó la
compra de bonos de los que ya hablamos
que es un bueno para estimular la
economía
hoy anunció que comenzará a reducir este
último programa ya que mantener esos
estímulos puede terminar haciendo más
mal que bien y le voy a dar un ejemplo
santiago las bajas tasas hipotecarias
han impulsado un auge en los precios de
la vivienda y a medida que hay más
consumo y menos oferta la inflación sube
y ya se está saliendo de control como lo
explica el presidente de la reserva
federal
los desequilibrios en oferta y demanda
relacionados con la pandemia la
reapertura de la economía han
contribuido a aumentos considerables de
precios en otros sectores en particular
los cuellos de botella en las
interrupciones de la cadena de
suministro están limitando la rapidez
con la que la producción puede responder
al repunte de la demanda en el corto
plazo como resultado la inflación
general está muy por encima de nuestra
meta del 2 por ciento a largo plazo
hacemos a los indicadores como las ffaa
las principales bolsas en la jornada de
hoy pues santiago justamente estas
decisiones anunciadas por la fed e
hicieron que wall street' repitiera su
triple récord en sus índices por segundo
día consecutivo el mercado financiero
llevaba meses esperando que la reserva
federal hiciera este anuncio y ahora
pone los ojos en las tasas de interés en
europa la bolsa de parís también repitió
la hazaña y vuelve a tocar máximos con
los ojos puestos también en la fed y en
américa latina la bolsa de buenos aires
cerró con un alza de más del 3 por
ciento diferencia presión a 6,7 por
ciento tasa de interés tasa de desempleo
en la unión europea en septiembre de
2021 está levemente por debajo de agua y
mucho menos que el 77 de un año atrás en
términos absolutos 14,3 millones de
personas están sin trabajo en los 27
países del bloque comunitario sobre todo
grecia y españa- muchas gracias daniela
por esta actualización del mundo
económico ustedes gracias por la
sintonía quién france24 siga con
nosotros buenas noches
[Música]
siga todas las noticias del deporte
contra el 24 todas las imágenes todas
las reacciones todos los resultados
deportes en france 24 y france 24
puntocom
[Música]
france24 su ventana al mundo
liberté égalité actual y ti